[Music]
a pungent blend of onions cheese and cat
urine with hints of is that wet goat
most of us don't need more than one
whiff to identify that generally
unpleasant characteristic smell we call
body odor but it's a surprisingly
complex phenomenon influenced by our
genetic makeup age diet and hygiene so
what is this odor exactly where does it
come from and can we do anything about
it to start you just need two things to
produce that familiar scent your armpits
own secretions and the bacteria that
feed on them most people associate body
odor with sweat and it's an important
piece of the puzzle your body has
millions of sweat glands and they come
in two major types at cream glands are
found all over your skin and secrete
mainly water and salt apocrine glands on
the other hand develop at puberty in
your armpits and a few other places on
your body the sweat they secrete is full
of proteins and fats by themselves these
secretions are usually odorless that's
where bacteria come in every square
centimeter of our bodies is covered with
thousands of bacteria many
microorganisms thrive in moist
environments like our armpits there you
can find about a million bacteria per
square centimetre one of the highest
concentrations anywhere on the skin
lurking in this throng of microorganisms
are species of Corney bacteria
staphylococci micro coxide and others
when these bacteria feed on the proteins
and fats in apocrine sweat they turn the
odorless compounds into new ones that
can smell very unpleasant some of the
worst offenders may be sulfur containing
chemicals those give body odor its
oniony aroma carboxylic acids are in the
mix too adding notes of cheese these
molecules waft up from the armpit and
can be sucked directly into our noses
where they're trapped
detected by an array of specialized
receptors those can recognize odor
molecules at concentrations of less than
one in a million so what determines how
strong your body odor might be it
depends on the resident microbial
populations in your armpit and the
nutrients that your glands provide them
with your genes help determine what
compounds you produce and in what
quantity so everyone has a slightly
different set in fact a gene variant
that virtually eliminates body odor is
common in people of East Asian descent
adrenaline increases the ratio of
apocrine to a Korean sweat so body odor
can be more intense when you're nervous
bacterial composition and concentration
also varies between individuals and
plays a part even what you eat can have
a small effect on how you smell so how
can we deal with body odor washing the
armpits with soap and water helps but
won't remove all the bacteria since many
are buried in deeper layers of the skin
deodorants however inhibit bacterial
activity and mask odors at the same time
antiperspirants work by forming tiny gel
plugs
that block sweat glands drying out the
armpits while we continue to battle body
odor scientists are trying to understand
it we don't know why the brain often
interprets these particular odors as
off-putting but some researchers have
proposed that secretions from the armpit
could have a positive function - like
cementing social bonds and providing a
means of chemical communication we don't
know yet if that's the case for now body
odor seems to be just another smelly
part of the human condition
[Music]
for more ted-ed videos that people love
to watch but are too embarrassed to
share check out this playlist
[Music]